but I can't on a serious note I can't
really help launch this panel without
making reference to the enormous
contributions made to our reflection on
these issues these core issues of this
conference by my mentor and colleague
continents and my fellow graduate
student at Columbia University at Al
Stepan both deeply deeply associated
with this great University and as Susan
mentioned Alba died last week and we'll
miss him greatly I was very fortunate to
be asked by Alan Kwan to contribute to
the breakdown and democracy project by
contributing a reflection on the Chilean
case and one of the oldest democracies
in the world in one of the 14 cases that
the atom is identified as are fairly
consolidated democracy that actually
broke down let me just say a couple of
quick things Lintz took very very
seriously that the structured
characteristics of democracies in crisis
were an important fact the actual and
latent conflicts the inequalities racial
divides ideological polarization or
perhaps more dramatically when sub
alternate loyalties to try linguistic
groups ethnicities religion or various
combinations of these superseded lawyers
loyalties to the broader community
leading in other words to the phenomena
that the Italians called IRA then done
you know where the sub alternate
loyalist loyalties demand sovereign
state indeed this is the with the end of
the Cold War this is a Pandora's box
that has been open with all of these
sort of sub alternate loyalties
demanding a sovereign state and indeed
it's extremely difficult to impose any
state whether authoritarianism on what
is not a nation it is far more difficult
I think to impose or to try to create or
structure
kradic collectivity a democratic nation
state you have to have a nation before
you create a state you clearly have to
have a nation before you create a
democratic state but the central
contribution I think of the breakdown
project is that agency does matter
social actors individuals leaders
parties can make a difference for good
or ill so the choices really really
matter do they do do do they add new
elders and policymakers focus on core
values do that or do they let what one
lens called unsolvable problems become
you know something that paralyzes the
society I think are the Affordable Care
Act here do they gradually permit the
loss of legitimacy of the rule of law
the justice system's the legitimate use
of force do they gradually abdicate
their their own responsibilities to take
the high road to try to defend these
institutions and so on and so forth
and and in all of the cases of the
breakdown project you saw some of these
elements perhaps the single most
important was when the Democrats when
the moderates when the folks that really
were supposedly committed to the
institutions began to sort of bail out
before a whole host of various
complicated reasons and I think that
these reflections might be very
important for our thinking about what's
happening in this country at this
particular time I'm fairly optimistic
myself I'll just finish with that I
happen to be now an advisor coming to
Denver leanness law firm in Washington
DC it's an amazing law firm it's the law
firm of Dean Acheson you know president
the creation and it's a regulatory law
firm it's the quintessential Washington
law firm the Eric Holder just went back
to the firm he's representing the
University of California system on Doc
you know the firmest taken many of the
cases on the travel ban through the
various different courts like that the
projects on the issue of redistricting
are also being addressed by them etc etc
etc I think that there are folks that
are trying to to come up to the
challenge that that Quan and Al insisted
on and that is it is up to all of us to
really sort of pitch in and to work to
make sure that these institutions don't
collapse I will stop there let's turn to
our panelists let's begin with with Adam
who has a broader paper and and then go
down through the suit with various
panelists and we'll open it up to
questions
how many minutes I think 10 to 12 can
you give make this three minutes short
we can't see
as I moved back to the hero forward
yes
right or down here yeah
this just foolin them
so if you regress probability a
democracy falling on per capita income
you will find the probability of
democracy been outright collapse of
democracy in the United States
conditional income is zero or one in
point one six million I think I can if
you do the same conditioning the
collapse of democracy on the number of
passed electoral defeats of incumbents
that probably is gonna be zero so if you
want to learn lessons from history we
should probably just go home our hmm
enjoy our afternoon drink I think if
we're here and if some of you or us are
nervous it's because we think that maybe
the current conditions are in some ways
unique or unprecedented the problem was
learning from history is that if current
conditions are unprecedented
history is no guide but the question is
so are they unprecedented are they
unique I think not and that's really
what I'm going to do first I'm going to
give you a little table unfortunately
reading tables takes time so I'm gonna
be extremely quick and then I'm going to
go sort of conditioned by condition of
various candidates of what may be
unprecedented what you see here is the
following there were 88 democracies
since 1918 that were consolidated in the
sense of having had experienced at least
two partisan changes in the office of
chief executive resulting from elections
so there were 88 of them of those
fourteen collapsed and the remaining 74
are still around
what you see the first two columns of
various averages for various conditions
of those democracies that survived up to
2008 those that fell before 2008 what
you see in the third column is are the
conditions of these democracies that
survived until 2008 after 2008 and your
last column is the US as you see it's
kind of the results of banal income
matters gross matters functional
inequality labor share matters household
equality both before transfers and taxes
and after taxes and transfers matters
presidential regimes are more vulnerable
and I'm not going to come government
crisis if you look at compare the recent
conditions from the past conditions you
see the recent conditions tend to be
sort of halfway between those
democracies that fail and those
democracies that survive and you can
draw conclusions about the u.s. from
yourself
so let me know entertain various
candidates for what may be unprecedented
as you know we've experienced during
some long period of time combination of
relatively slow growth was increasing
inequality which results in most
developed democracies and the stagnation
of incomes of some 30% 40% 50% of the
bottom of ink
recipients it's hard to tell whether
this is unprecedented or not because we
don't have earlier in a call it data so
we cannot look at log trends by income
desire or winter what I do find
unprecedented and perhaps hominis is
what you see now that 64 percent of
survey respondents in Europe and 60 in
the US now believe that their kids are
not going to be better off than they
were now that I think is well first
these beliefs are justified there's a
beautiful study by Chile at all which
shows that in fact it's 90 percent of 30
year old offsprings of sorry yes we're
better off than their parents in 1970 if
the United States and now it's only 50
percent that I think is unprecedented
since 1820 in the Western world we
believe that in material progress we
believe that our kids are going to be
better off than we were so that fact
that that belief is shaken and shaken
for good reasons is for me deep and
ominous causes I'm not gonna say
globalization China economists disagree
don't believe alter in his various
writings it's very hard to figure out
what the welfare effect of China and
NAFTA are we know that that certainly
some uncompensated losers we know that
being an uncompensated loser being in a
district that is negatively affect
by trade the increases the probability
of radical right voting both in the
United States and in Europe but
numerically these effects are tiny seven
tenths of one percent of the vote in
Europe
my favorite hobby horse and this is
going to be something which I hope is
going to open your mouth is this picture
but you see here this is for the US
trends in productivity per our work and
in our compensation look what happens
the same mister of eight European
countries basically until a certain date
we had were like God plus compromise
increases of wages follow increases
productivity final distribution of
income because it's stable and then it
comes to out of the girly-girl the
rooster Ozzy neoliberalism yes and of
connectivity increases wages not that I
think shapes the foundation of
democratic class compromise it's also
true for eight European countries after
1999 in Europe it opens up in 1990 what
strikes me this I have no idea what it's
unprecedented or not it strikes me that
people tend to think in racist terms yes
they vary greatly in racism as you see
yes from the Czech Republic to Sweden
but this is Europeans but there was
distinguished Muslims Jews and Gypsies
so it's just the perspective yes that
they have is formulated in terms of
ethnicity
finally there are political science
approaches in you may or may not love it
the European party systems
we're basically crystallized in the
nineteen twenties
22000 the same parties we're getting no
chairs and we're from two thousand the
share of the traditional parties the
vote share of the traditional parties
goes down the number of effective
parties goes up there's every sign that
the traditional party systems have been
shaken up they're rather come right this
up turnout shut down this is just one
note but because it's I found
particularly interesting the rise of
radical rights is not associated with
mobilization of people who did not vote
before this is no diamond is Hitler in
1930 brings five million people to
devote half of whom they had never voted
before here you see I'm regressing
radical right vote share on turn on all
the slopes are down except for them are
so it's centrist people who are
withdrawing rather than the radical
right
that is radical exit the US I can show
you the slide I'm not going to even read
it but when you look at the comparative
context you will find that the US is
truly an outlier knows education
this I don't know if you know the case
in detail piece but it's really amazing
they compare mortality rates of
basically forty to sixty year old white
males across different countries in
every country that Martel is falling in
the u.s. is just Kyra
no conclusions I didn't present an
argument but just a list but a couple of
comments obviously collapse is no
deterioration there are all kinds of
ways in which democracies deteriorate
they have several times in the u.s. yes
mark RC Nixon about not I think I am
strike that institutions one in all of
these cases somehow there was an
institutional way out of this crisis
institutions prevail the point to which
which I find well central is I think we
experiencing experiencing it's not a to
some extent a political phenomenon this
is something that has very deep social
roots and they're part of the reason of
going into economics and into people's
expectations of intergenerational
mobility is because I think that the
current crisis is deeply rooted into
society so this you probably know 41% of
Democrats 45 of Republicans see the
other party's threat to the nation in
Europe you get the same language traders
look at this way in nineteen sixty five
percent of Republicans and for of
Democrats which means pleased if they're
off swing married a supporter of the
opposite party now these numbers
49 and 33
so this penetrates the family
I lived in Chile 15 1773 and I remember
there were rumors Santiago that some
father threw his daughter out of the
household not because she got pregnant
not because of political differences and
I remember we also this cannot be
repaired just tear it's too deep
that's what I'm afraid of and with this
I thought this we just really have to
think what's gonna happen if Trump fares
what happens is not fun fails Merkin
sales direct sales child fails to do it
to improve the life of their supporters
what next what's gonna happen to this
these societies which are deeply divided
when no political solution seems to be
work so let's not just you know go after
bashing Trump
I don't have slides go ahead please okay
I'm actually gonna speak um I I did do a
memo and I will speak to that but I want
to put it into a little broader context
and bring up a few additional issues
others in this group will be looking at
constitutional issues and a corpse and
at elections and Congress bureaucracy
etc and I want to think about a series
of other kinds of behaviors that we're
seeing that aren't just the voting
behaviors are voting attitudes and
because I've done a lot of work on
unions I thought I would think about
those in part though I'm not putting it
in a terrifically comparative
perspective right now though I couldn't
in QA but I also want to do something I
didn't do in the memo which is to talk a
little bit about the ways in which we
think about trust and confidence in
government and legitimacy issues which
is something else I've thought a lot
about so I'm gonna bring this whip that
in at the end so what I want to
emphasize is the important role that
intermediary associations play in
maintaining a democracy and in ways that
we're not really I don't think fully
addressed in some of the other
literature and one of the most important
of those has been unions and labor
organizations not just in the US but all
around the world they mobilize folks
they raise money for candidates in the
u.s. they're highly identified with the
Democratic Party in other countries
there are actually labor parties though
they are diminishing in power and
strength almost everywhere they exist
but unions do something else which is
part of why I'm particularly concerned
about their decline and let me just give
you a couple figures about the actual
decline and then I'll tell you why it
worries me so much as of January 2017
the total union membership in the
combined public and private sectors is
ten point seven percent of all non
agricultural and salary workers in the
US that's still 14 point six million
people just to give it that number but
these aggregate figures really don't
tell the whole story
only six point four percent of the
private-sector workers now belong to
unions that stem from the high of 35
percent in nineteen fifty four that's a
huge decrease and the other piece of the
story is that a lot of the union
strength that we do see is in the public
sector and that's under threat the
public sector and the private sector
need each other in order to survive as
unions but the the emphasis on austerity
the antagonism to government all of
those things are making it harder and
harder as the Wisconsin case shows but
many other states have now taken strong
actions we've seen a number of
right-to-work states those are states
that make it much harder have a whole
set of rules in place that make it much
harder for
means to organize and collect dues come
out of legislation in 1947 but are
really speeding up now so we're seeing
something happening that's really
anti-union and the crucial period in the
United States fits with that moment that
Adam was emphasizing in the productivity
the the divide between productivity and
compensation it's when Reagan comes in
as president and begins a really very
explicit anti-union so we're seeing
government mobilized to some cases and
certainly the private sector mobilized
to undermine unions and a lot of
language in the media and elsewhere
making unions more or less illegitimate
I do some work with on the gig economy
and the gig economy workers don't like
the word Union at all they want to have
voice but they can't see there's a total
disconnect for them between unions and
other forms of voice Union has become a
bad word and I think this is really
disturbing for a couple of reasons one
thing we can see among the Trump voters
is a lot of the true some of the Trump
voters at least are people who would
have been in unions if the manufacturing
sector was still strong some of them
still are union members and they're
really there again the people who really
are feeling the strongest dislocations
as a result of the transformations
deteriorations
in all those factors that Adam just
presented but the unions did was it
stood between attitudes of union members
have always been heterogeneous it's not
that all union members are progressive
it's not that there were no anti-racist
or art anti I mean they're no racist
Union members it's always been a
heterogeneous group politically and in
terms of attitudes but the unions guided
that
created an institutional framework that
over time there were many ante there
were many racist unions and and
conservative unions at one point but
over time they increasingly became
identified done with huge amounts of
progressive progressivism but with
social insurance and protections and
progressive policies largely
incorporated in the Democratic Party and
so and they were able and I can give
explicit accounts of unions that very
self-consciously worked with their
members in order for them to understand
why it was important to vote in a
particular way to act in a particular
way and the decline in that kind of
institutional arrangement has been
devastating for that kind of break want
some natural attitudes that have always
existed there but were mobilized in a
different way or inhibited in a variety
of ways maybe it was attitude repression
of a different sort but nonetheless it
worked for a while so when we see that
decline it's very disturbing and we're
seeing this opening up of the space for
a bunch of behaviors that are very
problematic when we look at
Charlottesville for example we see
people on the streets who might well
have been on the streets in an earlier
period as part of a strike or a part of
something else
the one good takeaway from all this it's
not a good takeaway but one of the
things that makes me less depressed
about it I should say is that if you
think about historical cases and we can
think of many cases in which the unions
were actually absorbed into the fascist
movement
into the not into Nazism parodist unions
were key to that regime we're not seeing
the organization's being taken over
we're seeing the people in the
organization it's been so the
organization's to the extent they still
exist are still trying to stand strong
against that kind of behavior but it's
not a pretty picture when we lose these
kinds of intermediary organizations and
associations that are sort of standing
there as part of the multiple sets of
protections that we once had I want to
turn I have another minute or two I
imagine I want to turn briefly to issues
of trust and confidence something and
legitimacy other things that I've been
thinking a lot about and it probably was
asked to be on this panel because I had
but got into the union zones we are
seeing though I don't like the a NES
measure that's now taken up in the
General Social Survey and lots of other
things of how we measure trust in
government it's really more about
popularity and it only starts in 58 so
when we say things like we're at
all-time lows which we are in this
measure of trust in government the
federal government do what we like most
of the time some of the time a little at
the time you know all times loads were
probably not since the height of the
post-war period there probably well
before that Great Depression might have
been a low period interest in government
if we had a measure of that but still
we're seeing something happening we're
seeing this huge secular decline in
measures of a variety of measures of
confidence and trust in government and
we're seeing it not only in the United
States we're seeing it everywhere the
u.s. is not the lowest even among the
developed countries France is below us
or at least it was before leckrone I
don't think the measures have been done
since then so there are other but we're
singing everywhere just about there a
couple of countries that are escaping it
but not men
what I want to say here is that the
trust and confidence in government
measures however we measure them and
their variety of ways to do that other
than surveys I do a lot of work on
compliance with various government
obligations is that their basic that
measure is really in that way of
thinking about things is really based on
whether government is delivering goods
and services that people value or not
and whether it's doing it in a way that
people believe is procedurally fair or
not legitimacy it seems to me is a
different thing so we're certainly
seeing an anti-government feeling and a
feeling that it's not being responsive
but is that turning into a legitimacy
crisis which is another question and
legitimacy it seems to me is not just
about goods and services its whether we
really feel normatively positively about
government whether we think government
is has a right to exist and whether the
people who are populating it are have a
right to be there and it looks to me and
we don't have good measures of this and
it's very hard to have good measures of
this but if you look at what's happening
in the streets in a variety of other
settings it looks like they're more and
more people who are really doubting the
legitimacy of either government itself
or the particular people who are
populating government and it's not just
happening in the United States and that
seems to me a real concern and what's
something we should be paying attention
to
thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
at a time when many of us are worried
about Democratic erosion in the United
States and abroad it's useful to
remember that this is not the first time
that established democracies have seemed
under threat in the 1940s Hayek worried
that collectivist ideologies of both the
left and the right were endangering
democracies Hayek feared that even
Americans might inadvertently destroy
their democracy by putting too much
power in the hands of government which
would then abuse those powers now the
source of danger isn't collectivist
ideologies the dangers lies I'd like to
suggest in the erosion of a very basic
element of the democratic system which
is tolerance of differences of opinion
and differences of lifestyle substantial
parts of the US citizenry are split into
intolerant communities communities that
are willing to limit the free exchange
of ideas and suspend the rule of law
selectively for some higher purpose now
the most basic level there's a coalition
of citizens or suspicious of
globalization fearful of cultural change
economically insecure and hostile to
trade and immigration there's no
agreed-upon term to describe this art
coalition that's called them nativists
or America or the America first
coalition this overlaps I think very
significantly with a group that Adam was
describing people who believe that their
children
be worse off than themselves there's a
rival coalition of groups that define
themselves according to some form of
identity chiefly gender ethnicity or
sexual orientation or that consider
these identities crucial they emphasize
group rights again we have no collective
name for analytic purposes let's call
this the identitarian coalition I don't
want to take too much time
pointing to signs of growing intolerance
on the part of these groups because
you're familiar with them let me just
list on the nativist side the alarmism
of talk-radio conservative talk radio
the intransigence of the tea party the
themes and chants at Trump's rallies the
Muslim bands frequent characterizations
of Trump's opponents as unamerican or or
unpatriotic and on the identitarian side
there is advancing political correctness
on campuses and in mass entertainment
safe spaces are predicated on the notion
that dialogue with the other side is
harmful you know about the violent
responses to speakers on various
campuses an ACLU representative just a
few days ago was prevented from speaking
at William and Mary now there's nothing
unusual about Americans pursuing their
interests through groups Tocqueville saw
collective action by innumerable
American groups as one of the strengths
of American democracy moreover in the
America that talked view so admired
associations enforced norms
and they had strong convictions groups
brought together like-minded people and
they excluded people with different
priorities what's different about the
two coalition's that I'm characterizing
as intolerant communities is that they
hold everyone else to their own
standards
which they consider above criticism they
don't respect the other side they aren't
willing to listen to objections they
don't even consider the other side
legitimate the call an opponent
unamerican
is to D legitimize them to characterize
someone as deplorable is that dehumanize
them now the in tolerances of the two
sides are mutually dependent people hate
because they feel they're hated they
censor because their own views are
dismissed and suppressed they lack
empathy because their own problems are
unrecognized by the other side
conservative talk radio denies the
difficulties of being gay in the United
States universities aren't alarmed by
the problems or not sufficiently alarmed
by the problems of uneducated white
Americans people that case and Deaton
identified and discussed members of what
I'm calling an intolerant community
don't consider themselves intolerant in
any negative sense they don't see
themselves as denying any one's basic
freedoms they think that they're drawing
boundaries are essential to human
civilization and this makes them
reluctant to or close to compromise
internally these communities are quite
diverse there are shades of opinion
their differences in priorities members
may have reservations about particular
parts of the agenda of the broader
coalition the differences don't get much
notice however one reason is that the
communities themselves are intolerant
not only toward outsiders but toward
internal differences they treat
compromise by their members as
treasonous differences get much less
publicity therefore than their
commonalities we
hear much about them another reason is
that Outsiders publicize their most
extreme and most outrageous acts so when
speakers are denied that voice at
universities this gets huge attention on
brightburg apart that whole outrage
machine goes into overdrive drive when
there's no incident which is 99.9% of
the time lots of controversial speakers
come to universities we never hear about
it in Breitbart doesn't say a word now a
society may have multiple intolerant
communities that coexist in a rough
balance of power and that's I think
where we are in the United States today
the present balance of power could
continue indefinitely the checks and
balances of the American political
system could indefinitely block their
extreme plans and if we're lucky at some
point one day a charismatic leader will
appear on the scene redefine the
political issues forming a new coalition
of the moderates and and the intolerance
and peel away lots of people from these
intolerant communities that's an
optimistic scenario but there's also
there are also possible scenarios
involving one side gaining the upper
hand and silencing the other remember
that each community wants to wipe the
other out
neither is open to fundamental
compromise if it gets a chance it will
force its priorities on the other
because it considers the other side
illegitimate so how much how might we
get from where we are now to an
authoritarian system to one where one
community acts on its hatred on a much
larger scale than we're seeing
today of course this is what I'm going
to say is speculative but realignments
have occurred in other societies in
other contexts and what has happened in
these other societies it may provide
clues as to what is possible the
communities may each be immovable in
their basic positions but that's not the
case for their individual members and
remember that in any given community
private views are more heterogeneous
than the public views that we see each
community has its closeted moderates who
are movable under the right
circumstances a shock to the system and
say an economic shock another 9/11 a
trade war a physical war something like
this could trigger public realignments
that then alter the political incentives
of others moderates on one side can be
the ones who start the dynamic process
and realignments can then feed on
themselves with the growing community
gaining members progressively at the
expense of the other I'm imagining of
course a cascade of the sort that we
witnessed when communism collapsed
people turned against the incumbent
regime as the cost of doing so fell and
the advantages of switching to the
opposition the anti-regime opposition
increase we think of the Cascade out of
communism as a liberating process in
this case what looks like liberating to
one community would be oppressive to the
other that I think is the danger of the
current the danger the current climate
of opinion poses I haven't said anything
about how this plays out in electoral
politics how plays out in formal
governance the polarization we
in Washington is a reflection of growing
intolerance nationally and I think again
Adam showed us some some figures that
that support this polarization of the
electorate has been underway since at
least the 1980s this is why presidential
elections and Supreme Court nominations
now turn into existential matters as
they did not before the 1980s if the
balance of power gets upset and one form
of intolerance gains the upper hand
plenty of politicians will be ready to
serve as its instrument in the various
branches of government a dictator may
happily dismantle with checks and
balances in the system on behalf of his
supporters with widespread support and
we've seen examples of this in in other
countries where there's been massive
Democratic erosion turkey of course
comes to mind and Hungary in Poland and
there's several papers several
presentations that we'll get into those
those cases so Hayek's feared scenario
will have materialized if we go down
this path which of course I hope we we
don't but from a different starting
point the starting point being not
collectivist ideologies but intolerance
within civil society within segments of
society thank you
[Applause]
so I'm not going to use lights either
because I really wrote more of a
reflection paper rather than you know
bringing tables and so on
and so what I want to discuss is how I
see democracy's failing and the period I
have in mine is 1950 to the present so
there are many other cases of democratic
collapse in the 19th century and before
that I'm not really considering and
there are basically three ways I see in
which democracies have collapsed in this
period one is at the hands of soldiers
of the Armed Forces the other is at the
hands of civilian leaders that win
elections and these elections are
democratic when they come to power and
the third form of collapse which is
really more a form of democratic
deterioration rather than collapse that
is very serious in the region I work in
it's that democracies can be captured by
criminal groups so I will discuss the
three of these forms of collapse or
deterioration we know more about the
first form of collapse there is
significant research a lot of it done by
you know people in this in this panel
that really we have accumulated quite a
bit of knowledge of why democracies
collapse at the hands of military rulers
and I'm just going to summarize those so
one important thing to consider is that
that military cooze we're quite common
in the Cold War era so there was really
like the mode of collapse
during that period and to a large extent
that happened because it was lit a
legitimate course of action the u.s.
really support
military regimes that promise to to you
know to fight communist threats and also
the Soviet Union supported extreme
guerrillas and communist parties that
really wanted to overthrow capitalism
that libera really a very extreme
polarization internal polarization and
that was not really conducive to
consensus building so so that's a very
important thing to consider in the
contemporary period I don't think that
military coups are seen as a legitimate
action and actually in many of the
countries that we study impeachment has
become a really way of getting rid of of
rulers that that people are really not
happy with so the second lesson from the
literature is that income inequality
seems to be very destabilizing for
democracies and we have you know a lot
of work on that in the political science
literature showing how giving the vote
to the poor in conditions where you have
these sharp inequalities threatens the
rich and the rich feel you know that
they need to turn to the military to
defend their assets there are some
possible results here because for
example we know that our prices also
redistribute and also a puzzling result
is that many democracies even when they
are stable don't seem to be that red is
true beauty but that I will leave aside
the third cause of collapse it's really
linked to poverty and lack of of income
Madame Schirmer sqeeze world has really
shown that powerfully how democracies
that are at a low income levels are
fragile there is a small middle class
there is largely illiteracy and they
become more vulnerable to collapse and
it's actually very interesting that also
came up in damn Jaworski's worldwide
Latin America was more prone to this
type of collapses and in part it was
because our region experimented with
democracy much earlier than other
regions so you have cases for example
like what Amala a very low income level
having a democratic system in the 50s
and those those regimes you know show to
be particularly unstable now my my
computer went to rest sorry about that
okay so and then two more points one is
that a history of coups but then seem to
also make systems more vulnerable
although again here we have to be
careful because even if you have a
history of course people might have
stops in the military as a legitimate
course of action consider Argentina
where the military is extremely
illegitimate nowadays and even when they
have very severe crisis they would not
look back to the military and the last
point that we learned is also that
serious macroeconomic instabilities
economic crisis or failure of the system
to govern really made these systems more
unstable so the second mode of
deterioration and at some point collapse
that I want to discuss and that is
really more relevant for the reflections
about the u.s. it's through civilian
leaders that are sent to power through
elections that are democratic and here I
do not have in mind systems like you
know Robert Mugabe scenes in Bible
because the elections have never been
really democratic there has never been
alternation of political power there or
even you know
Mobutu said saying sorry but really
leaders that come to power after a
democratic election and then they
gradually get rid of democracy by
undermining checks and balances and you
know at some point even repressing their
opponents and even bring in the army to
do that for them so some cases are over
Chavez in Venezuela fujimori Peru put
him in Russia or van in Hungary or her
dog I mean in Turkey and more debatable
case might be the Kirchner's in
Argentina and so then the key point here
is that these leaders are sent to power
through elections so it is an important
point to ask why voters supported and so
that brings a little bit you know close
to what Adam were saying about
a sense of like democracy is not really
representing a lot of design front
people who feel disenfranchised they see
the system as chaotic the party system
has one representative and really there
is some anger against the existing
institutions and in addition to that
what we also see is that there are
serious economic dislocations
joblessness a sense of lack of social
mobility so these groups tend to support
this you know sorts of leaders so I want
to give two examples one was winter room
when Fujimori closed the Parliament in
Peru I remember vividly there was this
interview by david welna in national
public radio asking a woman you know
about the Parliament being closed and
the question was well do you support
this what about democracies in Yoda he
asked and then the woman turns out she
democracy these guys have the Parliament
they Orly they only rule for themselves
you know fujimori comes to talk for us
so so nobody was there to really defend
the Parliament when he closed it and the
same you can say about Google Chavez I
mean there was this very oligarch it's
his system in Venezuela alternation of
political power but there was really no
voice for the poor this system had
permanently sort of ignore the poor the
poor had not really you know play any
role in the system of redistribution
there was very limited redistribution in
a very inegalitarian system and I still
recall the National Assembly after that
big win with 90% of the vote when when
he you know came to redraft the
Constitution it was the first time I was
surprised to see oh you know so many
black faces in the assembly I mean the
nice you know is this common in
Venezuela and obviously that was not
common that was the first time that you
saw those faces in in this in them you
know sort of in the institution and
apparatus okay so he to to this is that
they come to power through elections but
that they continue to mobilize borders
and and that's really I think where the
US will stand apart from these cases
continue to mobilize borders in a way
that
really amass a lot of power so when I'm
thinking about the elections that you
would have is wrong he was winning with
80 or more percent of the votes the PRI
in Mexico was winning at some point you
know with 92 percent of the votes and
what that really gives them is the power
to undermine the system of checks and
balances and that is really a very
different context to what I see you know
happening in the u.s. for many for many
reasons including federalism and are
very vital federalism here but we have
to understand how they amass so much
power and so one of the critical things
they do for it and this is very clear in
the case of Hoover Chavez but also it
was very clear in the case of Mexico for
example during the PRI regime is that
they use a lot of government programs
and resources to mobilize voters in
their favor and let me give you the
example of Las Misiones Bolivar Deanna's
that he would have is created he used a
lot of oil money to create this antal
system of her distribution with a
creation of health clinics schools and a
lot of you know sort of direct help to
the poor and what really was critical
about this is that he was able to target
these benefits to whomever supported him
there is a very interesting and very
systematic evidence with this my santa
list that the government came to his
hands the names of the people who had
sign against over Chavez in the
referendum and there is very solid
evidence that those people receive less
jobs receive fewer government benefits
and were directly punished so the same
patterns we observed in Mexico during
the era of you know Germany is that the
PRI really was able to tell who the
supporters were who the opponents were
and assigned benefits to those who
supported the system and really punished
those who didn't so in the end what
happens what we call in our work the
tragic brilliance of these systems is
that voters and especially poor voters
end up playing a very active role in
supporting this system but they're not
only you know these leaders are
left-wing popular
but they are also right-wing populists
and so that's what we see for example in
the cases of Hungary that I was
mentioning them and Russia and so on and
the way of mobilization here is slightly
different and it's it really it's about
racism and it's about blaming the
minorities blaming the outsiders for the
ills of society for the fact that there
is no benefits for you for the fact that
your group doesn't have social mobility
there is not hope for you and I think
that's a common strategy to mobilize
support and the question is whether this
type of strategy can really cement
popular support support the way you know
the travis's regimes and so on do it ok
so the key question here is is when
democracy stops being democratic here
and I think in my opinion is really when
the system of checks and balances is
undermined to the point that all the
Friends of the regime are in the
institution so as I was mentioned in
Chavez redrafted the Constitution the
National Assembly was elected with 90%
of his people he you know undermined her
limits he parked the court he you know
she you know do the Electoral Tribunal
according to his interest and so on and
in that moment there are no ways in
which you can really limit the the
rulers now what other strategies they
use well they started turned violent and
they start to turn violent against their
opponents they start jailing their
opponents undermining the Free Press and
so on that at that point we are really
talking about a different system and in
all the cases that I study they do you
know these sorts of sort of abuses so a
question that we really need to ask is
how these leaders can get away with it
and so I want to give three three points
one is that in in in many of the cases I
study they use a really intelligent
strategic to divide opponents so it's
very easy to co-opt those opponents they
want to act locally with the system
meaning that they want compromise with
the system so in doing in doing that you
bring them you know to your Parliament
you bring them to the table of
negotiations while isolating the
opponents that want to be sort of more
radical and that I'm not going to go in
detail what that really
play a very nasty role in the system
because there is no coordination against
the rulers second point is lack of
societal coordination against abuses and
I think Barry wangus has relieved have
written a very interesting paper about
how social consensus is really necessary
to put how to these authoritarian abuses
and I'm going to go a little bit fast
here but things like stream social
organization divisions are long
religions lines ethnic lines on or in
the case of the US for example really
strong divisions and on party lines can
really undermine these you know sort of
capacity of society to coordinate
against abuses and that is a very
important thing to consider the third
point I want to mention is that not all
these abuses are common knowledge and
that is also problematic so when society
has very different interpretations about
what happened it's going to be very hard
to coordinate so you know the case of
electoral fraud which I have worked a
lot with it's it's clear you know fraud
happens in secret so it's not really
clear for society whether elections were
really reached or not and the
information is not common knowledge so
that is going to complicate coordination
but fraud is not the only abuse that
happens so when there are all these
interpretations about facts or you know
I think that's really problematic and
lastly I want to talk about protest
because that might be one way in which
society really can put a stop to these
regimes and obviously we have seen a lot
of cases in which protests succeed in
bringing out Socrates down or this this
form of you know sort of we are
democracies down but I am sort of not
fully optimistic about this and the
reason why I say so is for two is for
two reasons one is that protest can
happen it can bring about change but if
society doesn't have a unified voice
it's going to be very hard to create a
new system and we saw that for example
in in Egypt so that is something that we
need to consider that you know sort of
social mobilization might not
created a new alternative when that can
be problematic and the other thing that
I recently are working on a paper that
shows that protest is paradoxically more
damaging for regimes that are more
autocratic and where there is more
repression that for regimes that are
more open so I have a system that you
know paper that really shows that that
you can paradoxically have very serious
costs to protest in you know
authoritarian regimes because obviously
you can be killed you can be sent to
prison they you know there is very hard
ways of communicating among people to
coordinate protest but when protest
happens it just signals a lot about the
underlying dissatisfaction and about the
weakness of the regime whereas in
democracies we see protests all the time
and so that is not necessarily sort of
signaling much and again it's a problem
of you know how with all these protests
with everybody you know voicing
different things you are going to bring
about social change so lastly I just
want to very shortly talk about the last
form of deterioration of democracy less
relevant for the u.s. but very relevant
for many areas of the world that I work
in so this is when three institutions
and this is democratic institutions but
the whole set of institutions are
captured by criminal groups so imagine a
system where criminal groups decides who
runs for office criminal groups fund
candidates criminal groups assassinate
candidates they don't like and criminal
groups appoint police chief's know so
this is really what I have in mind what
I call that sort of act a democracy
capture right criminal groups yes you
have elections there is alternation of
political power but really you know if
things were in in the way that criminals
don't like it then you get killed and
this is a really serious a very serious
deterioration of democracy in many parts
of Latin America so some parts of
Colombia during long periods of time in
Colombia where you have this association
between the paramilitaries and
politicians and today in many parts of
Mexico also you can think of under as
what the male
see some of these sort of very nasty
forms of rule although granted it is
more at the local level but I just want
to finish with this you know sort of
very famous case that of course you have
heard about the disappearance of the 43
students in an EOC Napa Mexico where
after investigations it really turned
out to be the case that them local major
had given these 43 students to the local
criminal group the local criminal group
kill them you know dumping in a mass
grave or you know render bodies and then
in the end there was another
investigation by an international you
know Commission and the investigation
also suggested that probably the armed
forces were involved in this
disappearing so at this point there are
more than 30 disappear 30000 disappear
people in Mexico more than 200 mass
graves have been found and and this is
the type of sort of routine activity in
which you in which there isn't you know
sort of no one to defend people from
criminal groups because criminal groups
are really sort of embedded in the
institutions and are really appointing
the Chiefs of the police in the in the
sort of municipalities so I don't know
really how to call this but I really see
in terms of for example human rights
abuses repression the murder of
journalists and so on Mexico has never
been worst than right now and our system
is democratic now so so that is really
something we need to consider but as I
say less relevant for the discussion
here fortunately
I guess I'll take the prerogative of the
moderator nest one question of each one
of the colleagues made a presentation
Adam you did mention that the u.s. is
the only presidential system with
indirect elections and I just wanted to
sort of ask you this question given the
fact that Donald Trump one was less
popular both than any president in
American history with the exception of -
given the fact that he only won 30
percent of the vote of the eligible
electorate not the electorate that voted
given the fact that the president the
exiting president had seven percent
approval ratings in he had forty five
percent and he's down to thirty five
percent
I just wondering to what extent this
will make a difference if you actually
had a situation where there was a
significant reform of this process and
an allow democracy to prosper not to get
into the - the issue of the Senate were
17% of the population likes 50 over 50%
of the Senate Margaret I was wondering
if if in your case you might comment
you're very compelling story about
what's happening with the union movement
what's happened more broadly with the
intermediate organizations to society
going back to Tocqueville again and I
reminded of corn houses book on the
politics of mass society where a
critical point is in fact the absence of
intermediate institutions or maybe even
Bob putnams you know Bowling Alone
what's happened more generally with the
issues of trusting confidence with a
society this always had a very very rich
tapestry of intermediate institutions of
all kinds NGOs etc etc at the local
level in all kinds of levels with our
enormous commitment to say international
assistance and things like that Tim in
your case I'm also wondering when you
said at the beginning of your
presentation that substantial parts of
the US citizen dream
in intolerant communities again I like I
wonder what that means what percentage
of the the population is in these and
intolerant communities
and how do they stack up in terms of
intensity I would think that would be a
very important thing you know yeah you
know what is the high intensity what is
the medium intensity what is the sort of
moderate or indifferent intended
intensity of those folks and and then
the polarization in Washington is
probably not that kind of a polarization
it's a different kind of a polarization
anyway and then finally Beatriz and the
three points in terms of the failure of
the coos executive aggrandizement
criminal groups in my own work on sort
of presidencies interrupted the fact
that eighteen presidents have not
finished their terms of office in this
era of democratization there have only
been two classic military coups
we're facing a situation of paralysis
and a per the situation of paralysis in
some ways contrary to the grand iseman
because these are people that are able
to muster majorities it's minority
politics essentially and here we get
back to the issue of presidential ism as
well where you have presidents that
don't have significant working
majorities in Congress so if you could
keep your response really short so we
could also open it up to the to the
audience I would appreciate that
so we start with you Adam I have no idea
I think just that when the former rules
by which elections in particular
organized manner ah offend people's
sense of fairness it's harder to swallow
the defeat yes
I mean democracy is all about swallowing
defeat that's what the game is about and
people have this instinctive
majoritarian feeling about it ah in
France a party which now systematically
gets about 20% of the vote and one
parliamentary deputy in 671 and somehow
people find it offensive its proportion
they think of my drawer already
proportionality so I think it only has
this kind of a minor effect there were
some people who after the election who
said well well well but you know this is
unfair because in fact the Clinton won a
majority I don't know it's consequential
I think presidential inverse of
parliamentarism is consequential but
that's a longer story okay thanks well
maybe the last panel of the day will
cover whether or not we ought to scrap
the electoral system
oh the electoral college and and
certainly get into redistricting we can
vote on that how about that yeah
that would win these yeah we could do
another survey of experts Margaret so
generally I do think intermediary
organizations are in some kind of
decline though I not prepared to give
you all the figures but let me just
mention two kinds of things that have
been intermediaries one has been
religious organizations and we're seeing
a huge decline in general religiosity so
that the kinds of there's a project at
the center that I run at Stanford which
is talking about the digitally native
and how they're developing their values
and one of the problems is that very few
go to religious organizations weren't
raised that way don't get values that
way and they don't go to the dining room
table at dinner with their parents in
the same way so there variety of ways in
which they've been social breakdowns
that doesn't other kinds of religious
organizations of course on the rise so
if Angelica was in the u.s. extreme sex
all over the world that become kind of
echo chambers of a particular set of
ideas and beliefs and that's then
interacting with the transformation in
the medium which we've all been very
alert to if you look at the figures on
trust the only thing that seems to rank
with the decline in distrust in
government is the disk line decline and
distrust in media and again people are
going to media what a Twitter social or
print or whatever to the places where
they're getting what they're getting
feedback on what they already want to
believe as
to the Walter Cronkite figure who might
have been making a larger message I
don't think we we've got a handle on
this yet I think this is something that
deserves a lot more study and we're
we're seeing things that we know I think
there's one other point to make here
that it's the effect of some of those
things is it is enhancing I think this
kind of social larger societal problem
we're seeing which has multiple factors
as several speakers have talked about
and that is leading to what is
potentially a legitimacy crisis a lack
of trust in media or government or
religious organizations doesn't lead to
conflict it just leads to
dissatisfaction or
but if you really have different beliefs
about whether the government is
legitimate whether the electoral process
is legitimate that's what leads to
that's really what leads to the conflict
and that's very hard to mediate once
thanks in my mind the the echo it I
agree with what you just suggested but
have you participated in the march on
Washington you know the woman's smart
I'm watching afterwards where everybody
was yelling democracy matter democracy
matters maybe there is a little bit of a
silver lining the religious
organizations or from media is that they
are fundamentally about distributional
politics and there's just not they're
not necessarily representing the poor
depending on the country so that voice
may still be repressed but there really
is a lack of voice for serious
distributional politics when you begin
to
the organizations that represent workers
demo so the percentage of people who
would be disturbed if somebody belonged
to the opposite party moved in next door
has skyrocketed the percentage of people
who would be offended it would be upset
if their son or daughter married
somebody wants the other party because
again skyrocketed and figures are far
higher than the comparable figures for
racer so the many people who would not
be offended if their son or daughter
marries somebody of the opposite race
but party is the the big issue why is
this the case because they would find it
difficult to communicate with them they
wouldn't even agree on what the basic
issues are the fundamental issues
requiring dialogue and the solution er
it was much easier in the times we had
labor unions were many more members and
the fundamental conflict in the United
States and around the world was a
division of the gains from labor between
labor and capital and the fundamental
conflict that was the fundamental
conflict in society and we use the
left-right spectrum to describe that
that goes back to the French Revolution
that is no longer the fundamental source
of conflict we have two groups of
society that define the fundamental
issues as very definite they don't even
agree on
so that's they can't even start a
conversation because they can't agree on
what the basic basic issues are so
that's one I think indication of rising
intolerance another is on campuses if
you look at the people willing to block
speakers it's not just a few radical
professors who are doing this there's
increasing support from the students
themselves and this is a certification
of rising intolerance and the the young
generations the polarization in
Washington and politics in general I
think is a reflection of this there's a
lot of talk about gerrymandering I think
that's secondary if not tertiary
voters don't want their representatives
to to compromise they will turn against
their their representatives if they do
get into a dialogue if they do try to
come up with a bipartisan
compromise this is a reflection of
what's happening in the in society at
the within civil society where we have
groups that are not communicating with
each other they don't know how to
communicate with each other and that
gets reflected in the in the system so I
think this goes back to what Adam was
saying there's a deep deep issue here
that is the source of the the
fundamental source of the the problem
and it's not just the institutions in
Worcester it's not just electoral
politics McMahon yeah I mean I certainly
agree with that but I think you have a
problem disassociating it from economic
issues and specifically income
inequality I don't know whether you've
seen the picture by Col Rosenthal
somebody which is a correlation between
Gini index income and ago in the US and
polarization and the House of
Representatives and it goes down and up
like a you the correlation of this is
overtime is 0.92 it's just almost
perfectly correspond so I I think it's
driven by economic issues not
surprisingly John
okay so I think this is a really
interesting question because I mean as
we know a lot of as I mentioned a lot of
them cases that used to be solved
through military coups then now are sold
by impeachment and things like that that
that in a way result from this paralysis
that you are talking about enables book
is really great I love giving that to my
students because it's really sort of the
new mode in which this these democracies
at least in Latin America were where he
focuses deal with the paralysis so the
problem with this is that at some point
borders my reach the conclusion that
institutions are irrelevant now and are
illegitimate and there is really no
sense in continuing to go to war and so
on
Milana has a there has a really great
paper about this you know when voters
reach this conclusion you know sort of
every politician is corrupt you know
nothing really works that really is a
big problem that in a way opens up for
this type of rulers that I'm you know
talking about so yeah all of this is
related in the end to the you know
legitimacy of the system now and in that
sense I do agree that there is an issue
with presidential ism that you know we
have discussed it a lot in you know in
political science but but it seems to be
harder to deal with these issues in in
this type of constitutional system
Thanks well our time is right now
we'll take how about three questions
that are right there and now and I'll
start with those and why don't we just
take all three and then you can address
the
and they can respond we'll start with
you there sir marks the Athenian
correcting his prescription the ills of
capitalism his critique of capitalism
and you know what was just said about
the correlation between all the things
we're seeing and the defunding and the
attacks on public education the science
denial I mean no one was talking it
seemed like there was this false
equivalence maybe have one party that
simply does not accept science does I
accept a fact-based approach it's you
have citizens united you have the
American Legislative Exchange Council
which was a way that big funders are
able to funnel money to state
governments to change laws that they
maybe couldn't pass on the federal level
they can attack it state by state by
state by state you know you can just
kind of go on and on on there's also
just massive voter suppression taking
place people we're talking about Russian
applause Russian
voter suppression efforts by the
Republican Party has been ongoing and so
I was just wondering if you can kind of
address this and the question really is
is the United States even a democracy we
have democratic trappings we go to the
polls but you can't really have
distinctions that matter between
candidates we live in an actual
democracy
[Laughter]
Bartman is not concerned only with
United States and Gareth but primarily
with
Thirteen's
South Africa and so on and part hand
says the solution
not only in developing countries in poor
countries and in poor countries in
particular since the organized unions
represent maybe the the goal of the
trade
80% of workers engineer in the informal
sector
bargain outlines a program for what
unions should do now I think that the
role of unions is intimately related to
the issue of trust I think that the
focus upon the decline of trust that's
been a bit from I've seen as a speaker's
name day is focused upon the issue of
trust in government I think the key
issue is trust
by citizen
the most most speed what cravings did in
particular was to educate workers about
solidarity solidarity means the
recognition that we're all in the same
boat and for the extent that there's a
lot of implement equality it's not true
that we're all in the same boat or it
becomes much harder to see that we're in
the same boat
we are so I think the increase in that
in income inequality has been with the
deterioration of citizen solution to the
strategy of sherry
sorry could could you wrap up your your
come in please
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
thanks very much humor wanted to take
that last one
Margaret you take the breeds proceeding
one and then the anybody in the panel
could do the first one and and we want
to wrap up very quickly because you did
a neck we have a neck another panel in
ten minutes
so gerrymandering is certainly certainly
a factor and it it is affected electoral
outcomes in numerous numerous states I
don't think it's the fundamental
fundamental problem the Senate which is
of course not subject to gerrymandering
because votes are state-based unlike the
the house it's also it's also polarized
it's it's for that reason that I
characterized gerrymandering is a
secondary or tertiary tertiary issue the
the fundamental problem with with both
of the coalition's that I mentioned is
that the extremists do dominate partly
because they shut down free discourse
within their own coalition and the great
lots of nuances and reservations and so
on don't get heard and partly because
the media and the rival coalition
focuses
the extreme elements in the in the group
and this is what makes the the in
tolerances we observe much more much
stronger much deeper than would be the
case if individuals could speak on on
their own thank you credit for here
because I don't think even if trade
unions could be rebuilt I'm not sure
they do what you want to do so first let
me address how hard it would be to
rebuild trade union movement in this
country and in other countries that I
studied as well Australia has different
but some of the same problems many
countries in Europe
first of all with each change in the
production form we've seen different
kinds of unions develop we are seeing a
total lack of imagination about how to
develop a labor movement and the union
movement around the the current forms of
production the and the manufacturing
sector has been decimated and the
industrial unions are therefore largely
been decimated so you know until that
kind of imagination comes into play and
I I've been arguing for that for years
and I don't have that imagination and
I'm not seen it coming from somewhere
else I do think that we have another
problem which makes this much more
complicated which is that the laws in
virtually every country but certainly in
the US and the anglo-saxon world make it
very hard for unions to build solidarity
even and I do think they do that against
for a larger social process they build
solidarity against bosses that's what
they largely build solidarity about and
there are a couple of exceptions to that
in terms of unions and I've studied some
of them but it's very hard particularly
as we
the Labour Party's just falling apart
and the kind of ideologies that again
the lack of imagination perhaps so it's
not so easy so there's a big step
between you know the call for a revive
trading movement and succeeding in
getting up Thanks revive trade you know
any additional comments or thoughts or
[Music]
since you made up a contribution to our
discussion if there is no particular
reflection on that why don't we take
advantage of the fact that now we have
seven and a half minutes for our break
before we have the next panel thank you
very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]